Silicone Valley mais ça ne sera
pas simple.
- C'est le terrain quiva travert
à travers le terrain d'Esso.
- Bienvenue au coeur
d'un des plus vastes terrains
en friche de l'île de Montréal.
ntiel fait rêver
la mairesse de Montréal-Est,
elle qui entrevoit une zone
industrielle de demain.
- Mais ce qu'on veut, c'est
des centres de recherche,
des centres de haut savoir.
- Les terrains à vendre
d'Imperial Oil font une fois
et demi la taille du parc
Maisonneuve :
53 hectares au nord de
l'Autoroute 40... mais surtout,
un lot de 66 hectares entre
les ruese
et Sherbrooke Est, aux abords
du port, du réseau ferroviaire,
et des axes routiers.
ANNE SAINT-LAURENT, mairesse
de Montréal-Est
- Dans mes mots à moi,
je dis le Sillicon Valley
du Canada. C'est ça qu'on veut
faire avec Montdé@l,D8z?l
c'est ça mon rêve.
JEAN-DENIS CHAREST, pdg Chambre
de commerce de l'est de Montréal
À travers le pays,
des opportunitésle-là,
il y en a très peu.
- Mais le technopole d'avenir
se bute à défi de taille :
trouver l'acquéreur qui aurales.
JEAN-DENIS CHAREST, pdg Chambre
de commerce de l'est de Montréal
- On peut penser qu'une fois
décontaminés, les terrains
vont avoir une valeur au-delà
du 300 millions.
- Les raffineries ont été
à l'origine de la prospérité de
Montréal-Est, mais tour à tour,
elles ont mis la clé
sous la porte depuis quarante
ans.
ANNE SAINT-LAURENT, mairesse
de Montréal-Est
on était la 4e ville
industrielle au Canada. Ça a
tout tombé avec la fermeture
de ces industries-là. Là,
aujourd'hui, c'est une ville
fantôme.
- La rue principale placardée
n'est plus que l'ombre
d'elle-même.
Les derniers résistants, comme
cette pâtissière, attendent
le renouveau avec impatience.
KIMBERLEY BELZIL, propriétaire
de Mamia gâteaux et petits plâts
- Ça peut juste améliorer
les choses, justement,
ter les abandons qu'il
y a eu. Revitaliser le quartier,
revivre à travers tout ça.
JEAN-DENIS CHAREST, pdg Chambre
de commerce de l'est de Montréal
Le worst case scenario, c'est
que les terrains restent comme
ça, pis se décontaminent pas.
- On va continuer tout droit,
ça va être une autoroute.
idéalement ça va être deux
voies.
- Ici, il faut faire preuve
d'imagination, parce que
les terrains ne sont même pas
raccordés aux infrastructures
de base, dont l'aqueduc.- Avec .
- C'est sans compter
l'inexistence de transport
structurant, l'avenir du REM
de l'Est étant devenu incertain.
D'autant plus que
la décontamination se calcule
en dizaines, voire centaines
de millions de dollars
sur plusieurs années.
CHRISTIAN YACCARINI, président
Société de dévelopus.
- La première opération,
c'est d'empêcher la disposition
de cet actif-là
à des développeurs privés.
- Le président de la Sociétéde e
sur les terrains d'Imperial Oil
depuis un an déjà.
- On voit le potentiel...
- Il aura fallu 25 ans
au Technopole Angus avant
d'arriver à un tel résultat,
un terrain qui ne représentait
qu'une fraction du chantier
de Montréal-Est.
- Le grand danger, en ce moment,
compte tgrandeur
du terrain, c'est que ce soit
les développeurs qui viennent
y installer des centres de
données et des entrepôts. Et là,
l'économie du savoir et tout ça.
- On craint que les sols soient
trop sou
de l'habitation.
Mais la vente des terrains
survient alors que la province a
débloqué des millions de dollars
pour la décontamination.
L'Est de la métropole peut rêver
d'un futur plus vert.
Ici Jean-Philippe Hughes,Canat